michael and my michael and chris guest
and harry sure were doing this acoustic
version of of all their music called
unwigged unplugged
and we were traveling all over with tiny
little mini tour first time i'd ever
done anything like this and i was the
backup singer for like a couple of songs
and i would i was basically wendy just
kind of traveling on the bus with them
and ironing shirts and going out to
dinner and he was staying up all night
it was so much is that bus stop wendy
but maybe
that's a new play i'm gonna right right
but anyway so i was just having the best
time so we that we're playing some uh
we're they are playing this indian
casino somewhere in on the east coast i
can't remember the name of it
um you know every it was packed
everybody was there to see it and so
joel mchale is there because he was
either playing another room or he was
coming in after us or something he came
to see them because of course he loves
spinal tap like most people and so um he
said you know
you gave me my first job in l.a i said
what
he said the huntress i was quickie the
clown
michael and i wrote one episode of the
huntress
called springing tiny or james remar who
was in it getting him out of jail
you should have james remar on your show
you know him are you kidding can you
hook that up yes dude i love roma are
the warriors and his his we were in 48
hours together 48 hours so he was he
gans
yeah did he play games i never watched
the movies you were great in that though
thank you i don't remember the names of
the characters like that so anyway so uh
um
what was i telling you james riemar so
james reamer yeah but but then joel
mchale john mccain so
anyway the huntress you cast in the hunt
james riemer was in it in the show with
me called and he was playing tiny
bellows so anyway we michael and i wrote
this episode called springing tiny and
uh
there was always like this cold open
kind of thing where we'd be going out
and getting uh
we were the bounty hunters getting
somebody it wasn't related to the rest
of the show it was just this opening
thing teaser kind of thing so we had
this guy who was all painted up like a
clown and he was at a kid's party and we
were going after him for for not paying
his child support
jordan and i so there's a whole thing
where i'm like jumping on his back and
and i never saw this man without makeup
he was uh when i came onto the set he
was in full blown
and it turned out to be joel mchale and
that was his first you didn't know i had
no idea but he wasn't he wasn't like
joel mchale that we know right handsome
yeah he actually took the whole couch
ryan couldn't eat my engineer ryan here
couldn't sit down joel was sprawled down
on the couch comfortable as hell we had
a great rapport he was he's a great guy
he's such a nice really special i could
see why people like him yeah he's just a
likable guy we we did something a couple
years ago or a few years ago called a
stupid and feudal gesture about the life
of doug kenny i played doug kennedy's
mother and that was uh will forte and he
played chubby chase which was ironic
since he
had a lot of experience we worked with
we talked about that